marine le pen est présente en ce moment
si vous ne suivez en direct en ce 15 mai
aux alentours de 18h45 elle est présente
dans les yvelines à versailles soutenir
les candidats rassemblement bleu marine
pour les prochaines municipales je vous
propose de l'écouter c'était lors de son
arrivée dans la cité royale et bien à
rencontre de nos militants nos
sympathisants nos cadres de nos têtes de
liste de nos colistiers futur pour
exprimer l'optimisme qui est le mien
avec des espoirs dans les yvelines avec
des espoirs dans les yvelines
bien sûr c'est une fédération qui a
repris un très grand dynamisme qu'ils
marchent très bien qui est une des
belles fédération d'île de france et qui
est manifestement parfaitement en ordre
de bataille pour ses futures échéances
concert des villes en particulier à
écouter il ya déjà je crois plus d'une
dizaine de candidats qui sont investis
nous avons encore des candidats qui sont
en attente d'investiture donc nous
serons je crois très présent dans les
yvelines nous reviendrons au cours de
notre prochaine édition plus en détails
sur cette visite de la leader frontiste
dans le département en attendant je vous
propose d'écouter ce micro-trottoir le
front national peut-il progresser aux
prochaines municipales notamment dans
les yvelines
vos réponses au micro d' elodie moines
je pense quand même qu'il y a des gens
qui en ont tellement marque
mais votre pont d'un porte qui sent sans
prévoir les conséquences de ce qu'ils
font c'est fort possible oui dans le
contexte actuel oui je pense qu'il peut
gagner oui y'a vrai problème de crise de
travail
et malheureusement d'immigration et le
problème de
des échauffourées de lundi soir sur
paris va en rajouter une couche c'est
possible oui parce que les gens sont
tous mécontents mais j'espère que non
ils ont jamais gagné et ils gagneront
pas et les emphases ou et de le prendre
beaucoup de terrain je pense plus qu'à
se passe parce que les gens sont plutôt
déçus de la droite et de la gauche en ce
moment donc qu'est-ce qui reste toujours
en politique sachez également que david
douillet est lui aussi dans les yvelines
en ce moment à magny les hameaux le
député ump de la 12e circonscription des
yvelines est venu évoquer les
municipales également à l'invitation
d'aurore berger candidate pour son parti
aux municipales a même nivea mot david
douillet qui vient d'annoncer via son
entourage qu'il ne serait pas candidat
tête de liste à rouen est la rumeur
c'est voulait pourtant persistantes
autour de l'ancien ministre des sports a
rappelons qu'il a récemment déclaré que
le mandat de maire était l'un des plus
beaux mandat c'est tentant avait-il
conclu david douillet est aussi l'un des
signataires de ce courrier rédigé par
des députés de l'ump en soutien à henri
guaino autres élus yvelinois l'ancien
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy est
poursuivi pour avoir accusé le juge
jean-michel gentil d'avoir est déshonoré
la justice il n'a pas l'intention de
répondre aux questions de la police
chargée de l'enquêté préliminaire
l'interview du député de la 12e
circonscription david douillet qui se
trouve donc à magny les hameaux ce soir
en ce mercredi sera à découvrir dans
notre édition de demain à 18 heures